running a business in zimbabwe is tough
the constant uncertainty over the
volatile zimbabwean dollar doesn't help
to make matters worse banks were
recently ordered to stop lending with
immediate effect
the central bank's temporary freeze on
loans aim to contain inflation and
stabilize the economy entrepreneurs such
as wonder manures are panicked his
business supplies mining parts
if i can get an order from the mine
it should be too big for me to to handle
myself so i go to the bank and get this
what you call soft loan
i do the service i do the job
i repay back my loan
so that i will keep my business going
but when we heard the news
it was to us it was a big disaster
because
we can't do without the dance
a few days later the decision to stop
landing was reversed and things went
back to normal but some economists say
the damage was already done and dealt
another blow to zimbabwe's image
internationally
you expect more of this
towards uh as they wrap the elections so
anyone who is thinking of zimbabwe to
lend money we have to think twice to
remain excluded in the global financial
system as a country until after the
elections of 2023 in july
zimbabwe and struggling to cope with
hyperinflation are used to sudden
announcements from the central bank they
know whenever there's a change in
economic policy or banking rules they
can expect more hard times
many people here don't have faith in the
zimbabwean dollar because of its rapid
devaluation they prefer american dollars
either to hold on to a security or spend
on business transactions but inflation
keeps rising and that's led to a big
increase in prices of basic goods
to help consumers cope with the high
cost of living the government is
allowing people to import goods such as
cooking oil and sugar tax-free but
that's expected to affect the local
manufacturing industry and lead to more
job losses
the covert 19 pandemic and the war in
ukraine is hurting economies worldwide
but maybe in zimbabwe's case policy
inconsistencies could also be to blame
harumatasa al jazeera